I'm writing every Devil's fruit in one
piece to figure out which is the best
one this is the pika pika know me the
light light fruit which turns your body
into light itself it was eaten by Marine
Admiral kizeru now in terms of strength
the light food not only lets you move an
attack at the speed of light but you can
also shoot laser beams from a distance
this is without a question one of the
strongest fruits for attacking 23 out of
25 points and since it's a logia it
makes you Untouchable to anyone who
can't use hockey and allows you to dodge
attacks at light speeds so it also gets
a stunning 23 points in terms of defense
and for special abilities this would
really shines when it comes to traveling
allowing you to cover vast distances at
blinding speeds without the need for a
ship 20 points and honestly this route
would be really cool to have in real
life as well because it would give you
an amazing speed and the ability to fly
it's great for everyday use so it gets 4
stars out of five 16 points there are no
real downsides to this route either
which means it's earning a dazzling 82
out of 100 points putting it at number
one of our list for now